donc là moi j'en ai pas dormi de la
night quoi j'étais comme ça quoi je me
suis ça peut taper à tout moment on peut
venir me chercher et l'a terminée
terminé terminus qu'est ce que je risque
pas verlan rappelle l'histoire c'est que
on a dit voilà et gilles verdez en plus
moi j'ai même pas dit je m'en fous mais
je cautionne gilbert dette annie voilà à
donner un prix pour les amours 60 mais
derrière il ya eu cette société de
production
c'est pas hitachi c'est un gaucher à
saintes sony voilà qui a derrière la
fidi caisses et des caisses et des
lettres d'avocats et on va te faire
tomber faire à ronger hanouna t'es mort
patrice carteron s'en est mêlé faire un
truc de ouf quoi tu vois donc là ils en
voulaient à ma personne à moi même
voilà et donc ça a été des lettres toute
la journée dans mes souliers et là ils
ont dit là on ira très très loin ils ont
quand même appelé la pauvre la juge
ça veut dire qu'à une juge quand même la
pauvre ils l'ont appelé pour lui casser
les bons becs avec ça non mais sans réel
orale et leur direction ou de casser les
couilles
non mais franchement donc été souscrits
question et deux ans après non mais
ouais mais non mais moi je vais le dire
et j'en appelle à france télévisions je
dois taper la patronne de france
télévisions qui vous attaquent ses
missions ses débuts heures calmer le jeu
tu comprends ce qu'on lit bébé oui hein
on s'en fout car le diffuseur qu'on a
attaqué par la maison de production
passée ça c'était peut-être une idée
alors cyril il ya déjà un premier un
premier point qui est important je sais
pas quand la plainte a été déposée mais
normalement ils ont l'obligation de
déposer une plainte dans les trois mois
alors je vais te dire la plainte a été
déposée mettez en 2018 quand c'est
arrivé
non je crois que ça été déposés dont les
trois mois je crois dans les trois mois
froids ouais je crois bon ensuite ya une
nouvelle procédure qui aujourd'hui
j'ai pas tous les éléments
ensuite série la nouvelle cette nouvelle
procédure de mise en examen pour
diffamation
elle permet au juge justement de ne pas
te mettre en examen
c'est vrai absolue merci madame la juge
pas ces propos sur la justice parce
qu'en fait cette nouvelle procédure
avant c'était automatique c'est à dire
qu'on portait plainte pour diffamation
le jeu qu'il était un peu les mains
liées comme ça comme il envoyait il
disait bon bah voilà je vous mets en
examen vous vous débrouillerez devant le
tribunal
là le juge va quand même écouté tes
explications
je dois rien expliqué non tu va envoyer
une lettre d'un avocat pour et moi qui
vais l'écrire mais j'ai quand même
quelques années que j'ai pas écrit deux
lettres écrites
c'était carte postale à ma grand mère
généralement quand j'écris des dattes
séchées des sms et c'est pas avec les
sms il va la faire nous et je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de diffamation du tout
qui tienne parce qu'en fait une
diffamation c'est une atteinte à une
réputation et l'honneur et à la
considération
là où dit que le prix voilà le prix payé
et des peut-être exorbitant par rapport
au prix de gros on va dire de cette
émission est donc on avait dit par
exemple les amours se détestent lassé
diffamation parce que dire qu'ils disent
que l'émission s'appelle les amours mais
quand ça que les gens qui sont en couple
dans l'émission se détestent il a
annoncé la liberté d'expression c'est
vrai je n'ai alors bachelot dit
les amours note la liberté d'expression
et la diffamation c'est un abus de
liberté d'expression un abus de liberté
d'expression sur un prix sur lequel on
n'est pas d'accord il avait une
procédure quel droit de réponse
ils lui ont utilisés ils n'ont pas
utilisé l'algérien dire bah non vous
vous êtes trompés c'est pas le bon prix
vous vous trompez sur ce que vous
indiquez sur les informations une fausse
information n'est pas une diffamation
d'accord c'est à dire qu'il faut
vraiment qu à une incrimination qui met
qui met en cause un honneur car oui oui
bon j'arrête là c'est à dire qu'on aura
fabien le coeur est ce qu'ils ont
l'obligation de dire la vérité sur ce
qu'on a dit parce que c'est bien là le
problème on est entraîneur on a avancé
quelque chose il dit que c'est une
formation est ce qu'ils sont obligés de
dire la vérité ou non mais la vérité le
problème n'est pas n'est pas si c'est
vrai ou c'est pas vrai c'est simplement
ce qui a été dit est ce que oui ou non
cela peut causer une vraie atteinte à
cette émission à la production de cette
émission est ce qu'on a et 17 ce sont
des voleurs non on n'a pas dit ce sont
des prix variés vont pas pour
grand-chose au puy à des pancartes
à partir du moment où on les a accusés
d'une commune comme une incrimination
pénale on n'a pas mis en cause lors que
leur considération et leur honneur donc
à partir de là il n'y a pas de
diffamation
donc le juge a dans le mois de la lettre
que tu as reçu va examiner les éléments
que tu as lui faire parvenir il va
regarder a priori la séquence et s'il
voit qu'effectivement il n'y a pas de
diffamation il n'y aura pas de suite
dans ce dossier sera ça sera ce qu'on
appelle un classement sans suite ensuite
s quoi ces deux minutes alors il ya
fabien lecoeuvre bien entendu attaché de
presse de personnes décédées non mais
c'est un classé en tout cas là la partie
qui tu attaques ne peut pas démontrer
qu'un intention de nuire d'alcoa la
chaîne i l'avocat lui maintenant j'ai
cru que quelques dossiers sur le bureau
ggd bon cas d'école autour de moi à st
donc on peut pas démontrer que
financière d'hanouna voulait nuire
absolument avec des chroniqueurs médias
est ce que c'était une bonne information
à ce que ce n'était pas une bonne
information
même si cette information n'était pas
bonne même si le prix indiqué j'en ai
chié alors
johnny alors alors m si le prix indiqué
n'était pas le bon comment on peut
savoir que ce n'était pas le bon est ce
qu'ils peuvent le communiqué de bons
prix non bien sûr
ce qu'ils veulent demander le bon prix
non ils n'ont pas dit ce que c'est pas
vrai 70000 et ils peuvent faire ce
qu'ils ont ils font ce qu on appelle un
droit de réponse ils viennent ils mandin
insérer un commun c'est ça la
communication a droit de communication
dans le casque peut me demandez
peut-être la juge a pu me demandez
peut-être un droit de réponse et que je
donne les lèche les montants des amours
elle ne vous le demandera même le vendra
demandera même pas puisqu'elle va juger
si c'est une diffamation ça ne l'est pas
d'accord juste une question parce que la
pauvre jugent mine de rien quand elle
reçoit ce dossier sur son bureau et se
dit pas quelque chose à [ __ ]
non mais ça rigolait l'aps elle a dit
mme nadia dossiers à traiter
elles doivent se dire puisque s'ils
l'emportaient ils ont porté plainte dans
les trois mois en nommant 1900 en 2018
et qu'ils devraient plutôt poursuivre
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle a eu un peu de
dossiers à la préfecture elle l'a mis de
côté avec brio rouillé pense qu'elle a
autre chose à faire
voilà donc laisser faire la justice à ce
que j'en appelle à sony l'a arrêté il a
continué à faire des baladeurs a été de
ca continue à faire des télés 8,4 callas
et arrêter de faire chier les gens sans
rigoler non mais vous faites chier les
juges là ils ont autre chose à [ __ ]
ils ont des trucs importants à régler
là vous emmerder tout le monde voilà
donc écouter si vous les avez un truc à
me dire appelez moi et vous allez voir
que je suis extrêmement courtois au
téléphone
[Rires]
et comme connu dans le métier c'est ça
voilà c'est tout donc écoute en tout cas
rollon merci parce que tu m'a rassuré je
dormais la peur au ventre
ah oui voilà le poser une petite
question à qui ils veulent om ce même le
mettre tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est vrai
ce qu ils veulent quoi il viole un peu
ce qu'on appelle un coup de pression ça
veut dire qu'ils veulent ils veulent
faire en sorte qu'on les oublie un peu
et que peut-être pendant toute la durée
de la procédure qu'on va mettre de côté
toute discussion autour des amériques
[Rires]
offensif bien connu les amours libres et
shit les vraies questions
je reviens la semaine prochaine mais
voilà que j'ai l'impression de m'être
imagine tu te retrouves en poule
c'est pourquoi passer dix familles sur
les amours leurs voisins de cellule dans
ses balises est balèze voilà je tiens à
parler aux téléspectateurs en a beaucoup
qui était inquiet j'ai vu aujourd'hui je
tends top tweets avec cette histoire
tout le monde ça y est me voyez en
prison un truc ça y est comment il va
faire est ce que ces huit pas de
délocaliser des studios ne vous
inquiétez pas voilà c'est sony qui a
voulu mettre un coup de pression
l'écriture et voilà sony pictures sony
pictures exactement puisque sony music
and art est d'avoir ainsi plusieurs
semaines et c'est sony pictures
voilà je le dis bien écoutez bien sony
pictures n'a rien à voir avec les autres
sony sony pictures qui est la société de
production d amour mais c'est eux qui
nous pète likoud belges ont donc un
grand comme ça sony pictures s'abaisser
rien soigner puis s'arrêtera pas ils
vont deux émissions dont la nécessaire
même c'est pas donc un creusois deux
mois parce que y'a sonics héros c'est
pas un drop sony non mais non c'est
comme quand tu dis tu as une kawasaki
tu vois ça va réunir ces japonais le
champ non mais c'est pas très gros sony
non mais franchement au sony pictures
non plus tomber des têtes comme ça c'est
qu'il sait pas
et de noter qu'en maintenant
on va